mon nom est branche et je suis un troll
pourquoi est-ce que je vis dans un
bunker de survie fortement fortifié parce que juste devant ma
porte se cache un cauchemar nommé pavot pavot
est le chef des trolls et ce n'est pas
sa faute, elle est si incroyablement heureuse
qu'elle n'a jamais été confrontée  un vrai problème jusqu'à
présent branche de cupcake nous venons d'être attaqués
par un Bergen Bergen il a fallu à tout le monde
quel est votre plan pour sauver tout le monde pour
rentrer à la maison en toute sécurité alors vous allez les
scrapper à la liberté branche de brûlure solide
j'ai l'espagnol et le stahma les os
s'allume électriquement
j'ai ce soleil dans ma poche tu es si bon
donc mes pieds sentent cette maison
ce cul caca ton quart de travail mais toi pour
toi il
y a du gros
tu n'aimes pas la danse
alors tu
comprends puis-je oh casser les
trolls de DreamWorks
c'est là que nous reconstruisons notre
civilisation,
il a tout ce dont nous avons besoin de
l'air frais de l'eau propre des mains douce
acoustique acoustique rencontrer les vêtements qu'ils
chantent ils dansent et s'amusent beaucoup
mais ces créatures ne sont pas que
ravissantes  ul
whoa ils sont délicieux les
trolls Omega DreamWorks